[Music]  Oprah Winfrey recently released a 31  year old video of her auditioning for  her talk show that's right but watching  it all these years later you really get  a sense that she was destined for  success check this out I was obsessed  with getting this job somehow after all  these years my staff hunted down my  original audition tape  I don't know how hi there my name is  Oprah Winfrey Oprah spelled opra age and  if you noticed it's Harpo spelled  backwards my folks did not particularly  like Harpo Marx we do not even have a  television set in our home for a number  of years  but no one knew how to spell in my home  that's right  [Applause]  you